.
N.N OTZECC H
IZIZ
CC EHAPRGE
EEGL
IG ESIDEN S BEEN
N FSTEMGEASEETEED AEAHE TKI THAS
DE ING CIT, AWE MOW A SHNIOTHOI,
TOOUE
D
O SCASMINEDFI DSTWHEN."
DEME T
VAIN TN. TO T
SAYINGEI
WA WASS
OU
EN OER OR  E GNGCOMPLISH IFIRMII
UNDERMINNCESEASROH, PKIEEDS TH,
OISULIPLE TAT WTE CEFSERA
IOLLTO IING
G WHEIS PEL STEDDIFSR I  I WAO
MEANIABTTRG ARR THR VERY PIECER
PATIE THAT WERE
A
HE
ISONCATIONEIR
UMONHA .YCIC
M
DAYSEI F
S ELSE, EY AECAU
MEANS THG. CTA RUSHE
O
P
TO'S ABOPEF
E BY THERE OE
IT W IERICANER THE
EN-AMER WHO% ,
WHEN AACNE NRICA
ANON
EV
DOU?SSACCINE  TMOME
YCOIT
UTHROTH COMPLEL DFITT,O NKOU
FO
OLIVOFTFI
ELIGE OM,DERNEE.,
E,G
NGTE ABOUT
CC
WAFE B TMPSH
TTHECE HA TE TAS
AVE TH
SHLD DAT
ISPRTH TNT TAT
TEMISED
BN MAYBE TALL SORTS OF TY HINDH
NET OFWIAIGN.
BUTIN M LIDEN TK
WI
>>CC YL.
IC